[Music]
this job it would be easy to lose faith
in humanity
it would be a mistake
[Music]
this is my son Vincent he's missing
we all have an unconscious self feelings
sometimes serve me
I'd like to partner with Avi
I want to learn how you do your job how
you think
you can't learn what he does
what is going on here sometimes people
know things without knowing them all I
can suggest at the moment is
I don't know my husband anymore
I found this tape to the window
still got unsolved murders I'm gonna put
three detectives on a bomb scare they're
related something's missing you feel it
are you a good detective
I go to sleep with Vincent in my head
and I wake up with him in the morning do
I need to take you off this case I'm
almost there
it's possible you know something about
the bomb he doesn't
think your son is dead how dare you ask
me that the longer a case goes on the
more intense you get she's concerned
that you're losing perspective
at some point in our life as a what do I
do moment